un colloque aujourd'hui au sénat sur
l'alimentation et notamment
l'alimentation des enfants au centre des
discussions l'obésité devenu vous le
savez un problème de santé publique
pour y faire face les initiatives se
multiplient exemple dans ce collège près
de toulouse
la cantine s'est doté d'un logiciel pour
adapter et surveiller les repas servis
élèves par élève marie-pierre samitier
francis ranger midi au collège l'heure
de la cantine
mais auparavant on fait une halte à
cette borne informatique où s'affichent
les plats du jour chaque élève choisit
son repas et si le choix n'est pas
équilibré le logiciel le dis ici c'est
le cas pourquoi l'expérience a été
lancée au mois de novembre
ici trois cents enfants ont une carte de
cantine personnalisé qui contient
plusieurs informations transmises par ce
geste à chaque fois au logiciel
on m'a demandé comment je faisais le
juger et à prendre mon collègue de bar
sur la part qu'a choisi seul repas
adaptés à mes besoins
ainsi ses deux enfants ont le même âge
mais pas le même gabarit ni les mêmes
besoins alimentaires et c'est le moment
de leur faire comprendre cette
différence ses profits c'est l'enfance
et l'adolescence un peu les habitudes
alimentaires ne sont pas très ancrée où
on peut arriver encore faire quelque
chose ou lancôme aussi plus facilement
ses habitudes alimentaires
ce quelqu'un d'adultes sont un petit peu
plus difficile ensuite rien
d'obligatoire les enfants choisissent
les plats qu'ils veulent mais on
constate tout de même une évolution on
prend peut-être un peu moins souvent des
frites que l'on en prenait peut-être au
début de l'année pour 7 et des
changements à ce niveau-là léger mais
sensible quand même une expérience
enrichissante mais qui ne suffira pas à
endiguer ce fléau qu'est l'obésité
puisqu'en france désormais 15% des
enfants sont obèses